is an actual serial killer uh this Ohio
woman who was just charged in connection
to the deaths of at least four men that
she had met for sex her name is Rebecca
Auborn she's only 33 years old clearly
lived a little bit of a hard life if you
look at her mug shot uh She's accused of
robbing and fatally drugging victims in
January a 2 in April 1 in June according
to a joint statement from the Attorney
General of Ohio and the Columbus Police
Chief and here is what the AG said don't
buy sex in Ohio it ruins lives and could
cost yours freaking Bast it is better to
sleep with people you know and it is
even better to sleep with people you
like and it is best of all to sleep with
your spouse and that I guess is
controversial today